Hello children, today I am going to tell you
that if you have basic
mathematics then what should you do
and if you have standard mathematics
then what should you do. So if
you have basic mathematics then
give more NCERT plus sample papers and it is
sufficient.  And by doing only this, you
can do well in board exams in these
mathematics and if you have standard
mathematics then only NCERT and
sample papers are not sufficient. The reason for this is
that you must have seen recently that
CBSE has released practice questions
which are a little  It
means that you have to do NCERT Plus
Sample Papers plus Atlist NCERT
Exemplar so that you
can do well in Standard Method Mathematics.